V ramaswami has just pledged that if
this decision is not reversed he will
pull his name off the ballot in Colorado
as well they have just tried to Bar
president Trump from the Colorado ballot
using an unconstitutional maneuver that
is a bastardization of the 14th
Amendment to our US Constitution this
was a provision section three that was
designed to Bar Confederate members
people switched to the Confederacy from
actually being able to serve that's why
I'm making a pledge today that I will
withdraw I pledge to withdraw from the
Colorado GOP Primary ballot unless and
until TR Trump's name is
restored and I demand that Ronda sanis
and Chris Christie and Nikki Haley do
the same thing or else these Republicans
are simply complicit in this
unconstitutional attack on the way we
conduct our constitutional republic very
clever political maneuver because it
puts the other GOP candidates on defense
and I don't think this is just a cynical
Ploy I think it's an admirable thing to
do